this video sponsored by Skillshare the
first thousand people to sign up with
the link in the description will get
their first two months for just 99 cents
hey wisecrack jared again while we were
working on our philosophy of saw video i
came across something very unexpected
apparently critics have noted a
structural similarity between these saw
films and french philosopher jean-paul
Sartre say misplay no exit so I watched
all seven movies read no exit and
immediately called both the connection
was too tenuous then jigsaw came out and
when I saw this I was like huh welcome
is wisecrack edition on the philosophy
of jigsaw and if you want more jigsaw
related content head on over to eyes
crack Plus on patreon for an exclusive
podcast that dives deeper into the movie
and as always spoilers and decapitations
ahead
like all Saw movies jigsaw starts with a
game each player has to confess the
horrible sin that snagged them an
exclusive invite to the world's worst
warehouse party if they don't confess
they'll turn dead AFUE given the chance
to save their skin each of the players
take a solid pass offering half-baked
confessions
or professing their innocence honey my
soul is clean so one by one they're
voted off the island meanwhile an
assortment of sketchy detectives and
forensic pathologists try to figure out
why gnarly corpses keep popping up all
over the city could be very much dead
John Kramer be to blame
eventually the film's creepy detective
and creepy forensics guy come face to
face in the ultimate creep off and we
find out that the forensics guy is the
new jigsaw I am oh and by the way
everything you just watched actually
happened 10 years ago but don't worry
about that instead of focusing on the
timeline fake-out we're zeroing in on
what brings fans to the Saw films in the
first place the wholesome games see in
the past jigsaw had one main party trick
building traps too heinous ly and
creatively torture people but in the
latest film jigsaws moved into a more
psychological realm forcing his victims
to confess their worst sins both
versions of the game consist of forcing
a person to choose between two
unattractive options
the device it's in the stomach in the
first seven films Kramer asked each
victim to choose between door a inflict
excruciating pain on themselves or
others or door B give up and die but in
jigsaw the games been updated now his
victims must choose between door a
confess to their worst sin in front of a
group of strangers and make it home in
time for Adult Swim or door B die a
painful death the game is still
sprinkled with head gnashing leg ripping
devices etc but these are more of a
sideshow a background threat perhaps to
encourage honesty the evolution of
jigsaws gained positions the act of
confessing as the painful alternative to
death the essential form of suffering
that takes place in the film unlike the
other films confession not the burning
slashing or ripping of flesh is treated
as the harder more pain inducing moral
alternative to instant death but let's
backtrack for a second what moves jigsaw
to devote his life to making DIY
medieval torture devices in the first
place as we explained in our philosophy
of saw episode Kramer shares the early
Christian view that suffering can be
transformative and even life-changing so
enduring his traps can strengthen a
person's moral character and even redeem
them for past naughtiness as leader of
this CrossFit for the soul jigsaw
establishes himself as a god-like figure
imposing his moral agenda on his
captives
similarly jigsaws new game draws from
another aspect of early Christianity
public confession and public penance
while today's sinners can spill their
guts in a low-key gossip session with
father superior third century sinners
were frequently required to confess
their worst deeds in front of their
entire church congregation and Act known
as XML Jesus and also a total fuckin
bummer according to early Christian
writer Tertullian XML Jesus was an act
meant to humiliate the sinner
essentially rendering them so totally
pathetic they would move God to mercy
likewise Kramer demands the confession
of his captives in hopes of shaming them
once confession was over the person
moved on to public penance where the
humiliation only got richer
Tertullian claims the sinner would be
instructed by their bishop to do things
like lions sack cloth and ashes the
ashes were a sign of mourning for your
spiritual condition they were forbidden
to bathe and had to eat only unseasoned
food and drink to pass the time sinners
would prostrate or live stretched out on
the ground groaning and crying while
begging their church leader and fellow
churchgoers to pray for them in jigsaw
Anna seems to be taking a similarly
penitent pose as she begs Kramer for
mercy
so like a third century church leader
Kramer demands that his captives
publicly confessed their worst deeds and
boy do they clam up the second chicks I
asked them to talk about their pasts in
previous installments the basic human
desire to keep both eyeballs has made
for a compelling reason not to follow
jigsaws commands this time it's just the
characters shame that makes them
reluctant to air their dirty laundry
this creates some decidedly baffling
moments best exemplified early on when
Carly finds out that jigsaw has injected
her with a poison that can only be cured
by an antidote found in one of these
three needles one is the antidote one is
harmless and one holds a potent acid
that will melt her face off and not in
the fun electric daisy carnival way
Carly figures out which needle would
save her life because one is numbered
3.53
which is the exact amount of money she
got after robbing and killing someone to
admit that though would serve as a kind
of confession so she doesn't say
anything so that happens so why wouldn't
Carly confess it seems odd unless you
consider the clue helpfully graffiti
tagged on the wall that sign isn't just
there for fire safety it's a reference
to jean-paul Sartre so a misplay no exit
first a quick breakdown of the play
three dead souls in as Estelle and
Joseph meet up in hell though this
version of Hell is less fire and
brimstone and more waiting room
wondering how they ended up there
Estelle and Joseph make like the saw
victims and lie about their crimes I
don't know in fact I'm wondering if
there hasn't been some terrible day
eventually each confesses their worst
deeds both Estelle and Joseph feel the
weight of judgment for their crimes
so what does this play have to do with
your favorite torture porn series both
center around a group of strangers
trapped in a room awaiting an unknown
but presumably horrific punishment but
perhaps a saw producer was guilty of
Wikipedia himself because the eighth
film really doubles down on the no exit
stick in ways both big and small notably
there's an eerie similarity of the
crimes committed by sartruse character
Estelle and jigsaws Anna
Estelle after becoming pregnant by her
illicit lover drowned her newborn baby
as he looked on he killed himself in
grief similarly Anna suffocated her
newborn child but convinced her husband
it was his fault forcing him to commit
suicide but now for the principle
similarity between jigsaw and
exit the emphasis on the painful nature
of confession do you understand why
confession is so hard in both works we
need to examine sartruse idea of the
look which he illustrates through the
following example imagine that you're
spying on your roommates awkward breakup
through a keyhole suddenly you become
aware that your other cooler roommate is
down the hallway watching you act creepy
and judging you for it this state of
awareness of being watched by others is
called the look when you become aware of
the look you are forced at least
momentarily to embody the viewpoint of
what's Archer calls the other or an
outside entity with its own separate
consciousness and embodying the other's
viewpoint you feel a major discomfort ie
shame which costs you to pretend that
you weren't spying you were just
smelling the doorknob extended over a
lifetime your awareness of the look
causes you to live in authentically for
what Sartre calls bad faith bad faith is
basically a failure to properly use your
freedom or take responsibility for your
actions and Cramer's prisoners certainly
seem to be living in the baddest sort of
faith take Carli
despite her clear choice to let a woman
die by not giving her an inhaler she
sees it as an accident however Sartre
would tell Carly that even in choosing
not to do anything
she still exercised her free will and
made a choice to watch this lady
asphyxiated
similarly Mitch Anna and Ryan all lied
revising history to make their crimes
seem like accidents or honest mistakes
Kramer essentially accuses his captives
of first being criminals and second of
living in bad faith in the past you have
all gone
and then lie to yourselves and deceive
the world about your callousness here
are notice Kramer's focus not just on
each individual's crimes but on their
subsequent lies self-deception and
cover-up no look in the mirror
Sartre similarly used the mirror as a
metaphor for the look of the other of
course Kramer's captives won't look in
an actual mirror he means that their
crimes will be reflected back to them by
the judgment of their fellow prisoners
that judgment can be torture all by
itself like a reverse bear trap for your
soul in no exit after the characters
confess their crimes they suffer anxiety
about the judgment of their peers fret
about their reputations on earth where
there are something that says they're
thinking gasa is a coward that's got to
think of something that Jeff Kazan is a
card and beg for reassurance that they
are not bad people
this leads Joseph to utter the famous
line hell is other people
not just because someone always leaves
their cell phone on in the movie theater
but because the existence of other
people means the existence of their
judgement and the shame that ensues
that's particularly true if like Joseph
you're hanging out with people who know
your worst secrets if hell is other
people knowing your worst deeds it makes
sense that confession is Kramer's new
favorite torture device he's trying to
force his captives to face Joseph's
anguish by making them publicly take
responsibility for their choices for
instance he makes Ryan relive his own
worst deed as a drunk teenager his
Joyride inadvertently caused a deadly
car crash he escaped responsibility for
it and tell all these years later
until Hanukkah now sergeant of hell in
no exit is not the only one that the Saw
series references John Kramer also must
have studied up on Dante's Inferno in it
the 14th century is Hallion poet depicts
his own presumably fictional journey
through the nine concentric circles of
hell each housing a different brand of
sinners suffering for eternity Dante's
hell is governed chiefly by a rule
called contrapasso Latin for to suffer
the opposite under contrapasso sinners
suffer punishments that are either
related to or the extreme contrast of
the crimes they committed on earth for
instance astrologers and false prophets
are forced to walk forever with their
heads turned backwards a punishment for
trying to look into the future or win
the Powerball chronic suck ups are
buried in excrement because well you
know importantly the rule of contrapasso
means that a person's eternity in hell
is predestined by their own freely
chosen sins throughout the saw series
kramer shows some flair for contrapasso
punishment think of the time he forced a
heroin junkie to dig through a pit of
needles in search of a key get it like
her addiction is the trap or the cruel
moneylenders who had to pay for their
lives in pounds of flesh or the
voyeuristic sex offender who had to
gouge his eyes out or lose all his limbs
Kramer's traps and jigsaw also share
some of the same poetry as Dante's
Inferno
for instance we learned that Mitch sold
a motorcycle with a faulty brake to
Kramer's nephew who later died in an
accident so what was Mitch's trap
secured this brake lever or be sliced up
by a circular metal blade and a jams the
machine and we think mitch is saved but
fittingly her homemade brake lever is
faulty and Mitch plummets into a death
spiral later Kramer presents the last
two survivors Ana and Ryan with their
final game in the form of a single
shotgun and a vague riddle now if you
want to achieve your freedom
you have to realize that you've been
doing a backwards Anna immediately
lunges for the gun assuming that to win
the game she has to shoot Ryan but then
a broken key falls out
Kramer had stored the key to their
freedom inside the weapon here Anna
shows that she hasn't changed she
remains willing to ruin or take another
life to save her own
according to Kramer's reasoning Anna is
ultimately trapped and killed not by his
game but by her fundamental moral
failings we're jigsaw stops making sense
though is when her choice also causes
Ryan to be trapped in the barn after he
at least somewhat assumes responsibility
for his deadly Joyride and from there on
jigsaw seems to abandon any semblance of
a moral lesson moving from the doomed
barn adventures to the less interesting
laser collar trap holding detective
Halloran and Logan the forensics guy
they each make their own confessions
and then Logan fakes his death comes
back to life and reveals that he's the
new jigsaw then he leaves Halloran Firth
dead savage Logan maybe John Kramer's
one-man tribute band but will he further
the moral philosophy of the series looks
like we'll find out soon enough there's
already talk of a 9th Saw movie with
Logan's final declaration I speak to the
dead it sounds like we're in for some
forensic pathologists gone wild but what
do you think was jigsaw and insightful
philosophical inquiry or just an excuse
to watch a guy get shredded into
confetti and is Logan a generic creep
with all the charisma of a latex glove
or the fresh new villain the Saw series
needed let us know in the comments and
as always thanks for watching
peace if John premiers knowledge and
skills at trap building leave you
envious head on over to skill share to
pick up the skills you need to become a
mastermind Skillshare is an online
learning platform with more than 18,000
courses and Counting skill share is
adding new classes all the time
want to learn how to make films ordinate
your own beanie or maybe just take nice
pictures of your friends check out
street shots photographing scale light
and colors taught by none other then
Steve sweatpants that's right you can
learn photography from a guy named Steve
sweatpants or check out the art of the
story creating visual narratives taught
by Debbie Millman to learn the
foundations of visual storytelling
there's something here for everyone and
with the classes run by experts in their
fields it can't go wrong premium
memberships give you unlimited access to
these and thousands of expert-led
classes that will teach you to master
and promote your business side hustler
or creative endeavors and with annual
subscriptions starting at less than $10
a month Skillshare is one of the most
affordable learning platforms on the web
be one of the first thousand people to
sign up at SK LS h slash wisecrack v or
through the link in the description to
get your first two months of Skillshare
for just 99 cents follow the link below
to get started that's all for me thanks
for watching y'all peace go to school
excuse chair woody says go to Skillshare
get yourself some skills